YOSHIFUMI YAMAGUCHI: I'm
Yoshifumi Yamaguchi, developer
advocate, usually
based on Tokyo office.
I started working on the
developer relations team
from last quarter.
And before that, I have
been working in YouTube
as a technical
account manager, which
like technical sales to
the YouTube partners.
So I have been working in the
YouTube for almost three years.
So in the keynote, and
in the last section,
we have explained how to create
your application properly,
or more sophisticated.
So in the last two keynotes,
and the last section,
we have been talked about how
to create your application more
properly, or more sophisticated.
But if your application
is not [? available ?]
on the internet,
or anywhere else,
your application is not going
to be used by lots of users.
So in that sense, YouTube API
is really great because you
can [INAUDIBLE] your
application on the internet
and then you don't have to
create the content by yourself.
So you can let users
to great content
by using your application.
So today I'd like to talk about
how to integrate YouTube API,
and also I'd like to
introduce the [INAUDIBLE]
for use cases using YouTube API.
So here's the agenda.
Before starting
introduction of YouTube API,
I'd liked to introduce the
feature of YouTube itself
because this is the
key of this strategy
and then move onto
YouTube API stuff.
And then, after that, I'm going
to introduce the developer
ecosystem surrounding
the YouTube API
and then going to
the Q&A session.
So before starting
introducing YouTube API,
I'd like to introduce
YouTube service itself
because that expresses the
reason why YouTube can energize
your application and
increase your user
engagement to your applications.
So I'd like to show you some
stats as an explanation of how
big YouTube is as a
video provider service.
So the first one, YouTube has
over one billion unique users
per month.
That means more than 150
million unique users per day.
And then it is
continuing to grow fast.
So maybe this stat is one year
ago, but the latest one maybe
more than this one.
And also, there is four
billion views per day.
So with the stats above,
so in rough calculation,
each unique user consume
24 videos per day.
So don't you think this
is kind of big number.
And another aspect of
consuming, so all YouTube users
are spending six billion hours
per month on watching videos.
And not only the consumption of
content, but also the creation
of content, is immensely active.
The total length of videos
uploaded onto YouTube
in every single minute
reaches over 100 hours.
Over 100 hours of video
are uploaded on YouTube.
So can you imagine
how big is this?
And let us shift
the point of view
to the diverse devices where
the YouTube videos are played.
So recently, as you
know, the mobile devices
is really popular--
especially in APAC region
and in Korea as well.
And more than 40% of watch
time are from mobile.
So in the case of APAC,
the number of the rate
is more than that,
maybe more than half.
So the half of
people are watching
the video on the mobile.
And then half of
people are watching
the video on the devices.
So you have to take serious
care of mobile development,
especially on YouTube as well.
So with these stats,
what I'd like to say
is that if you don't have
no channels on YouTube,
that means you don't
have any presence
to the internet, or the users.
So it is really
important to have
the connection to the YouTube.
But I agree that
every developer can
create a
professional-like video.
I'm not trying to say create
a TV commercial-like video
and put it on YouTube.
But I'd like to say that
let users to create content
and then try to [INAUDIBLE]
your application
through those users'
uploaded video.
So that is the key
to take advantage
of the power of YouTube API.
So here's interesting
statistics.
Research is three years ago, so
the number is more than this.
So 90% of serious
gamers are watching
the user-uploaded
videos on YouTube,
users uploaded gameplay
videos on YouTube.
And 94% of those are watching
[? off ?] [? show ?] game
trailers.
So the game players are watching
user-generated video more
than the [? off show ?]
trailers.
So these stats
prove the importance
of user-generated
content on YouTube.
So look at these two pictures.
The one is "Trial Extreme Three"
And the other is "FIFA '13".
And both has that
kind of uploading
user-generated content feature.
And then they
succeeded of the sales.
And they also-- that
left cat is the logo
of Talking Tom, which is the
first famous mobile application
using the YouTube API.
And those three achieved
great success on YouTube
using the upload API.
So that is why I emphasize on
the YouTube API for our game
developers.
So now I'm moving on to
why I use the YouTube API.
So Google is always
adding new features
to help our API partners,
and content partners,
to improve their
applications and content.
So recently, YouTube
released new features
to our YouTube API, such as
a subscription widget, which
allows the YouTube channel owner
to put the subscription button
outside of YouTube.com site,
such as their own website.
And there's also a
live streaming API,
and a video programming
API, and a channel
branding API, et
cetera, et cetera.
So the reason why we are
trying to put lot of features
to the YouTube
API is that we are
trying to make YouTube APIs
equal to YouTube itself.
So let me explain about this.
So the overview of
a YouTube API is
that its intent
is making YouTube
to be more similar
to YouTube itself.
But we'd like to let developers
to utilize all the features
on the YouTube outside
of YouTube.com.
In YouTube, we have
three features.
So one is playback.
So if you access
through YouTube,
you're going to search
some video with some query,
and then find a video,
and then play it.
This is the basic
feature of YouTube.
And then the playback is the
most important part of YouTube
because YouTube is a
game providing service.
Without the playback service,
you cannot enjoy the video.
So the playback feature
is coming first.
So you can play a YouTube
video on Android, iOS, HTML5,
and then Flash.
So all of the platforms are
covered with YouTube API.
The second thing is utilizing
the YouTube.com features
outside of it.
So, for example, uploading
video, and then finding video,
and then also putting live
stream content on YouTube,
and modifying the video content,
modifying video metadata,
or channel metadata,
and also investigating
user activities, or video
stats outside of YouTube.com
Then the last one is analyze.
So YouTube has the dashboard
called YouTube Analytics,
which enables users to
investigate how the video is
consumed, such as-- so which age
of people are watching video?
Or which area is this
video popular, or something
like that?
So you can use analytics APIs
to investigate user activities.
So far, I have been focusing
on describing the YouTube
and YouTube API.
But I think what
you'd like to know
is how the actual developers
achieved the access using
YouTube API.
So now move onto
the actual use cases
and then taking
advantage of YouTube API.
So this picture is showing
the developer system
around YouTube.
And the areas are
divided into four.
The one is creators, and
then marketers, enterprises,
and then viewers.
And then, in this
section, I'd like
to focus on the creation
section, creators section,
because game and
the live streaming
is really popular here in
Korea, and also this event
is about mobile.
So I'd like to focus
on the creation part.
So let's start from
EA's "FIFA 13."
Has anyone played "FIFA
13" on the iPad or iPhone?
No one?
OK.
So let me introduce.
So "FIFA 13," is, as you
see here, is a soccer game.
And it allows users shoot
scenes of the match,
and then the record is
processed automatically.
And then it enables users
to share the content
onto the YouTube, as you
can see in the screenshot.
So if you press
the YouTube button,
then the recorded video is going
to be shared on the YouTube.
So this is really easy workflow.
And then you can
watch the actual video
uploaded on the
YouTube like this.
So this is a really
short one, but you
can find out a longer
one on YouTube.com.
So if you are
interested in this,
please find some
videos on YouTube.com.
And some users are creating
the lists of best goals
in this season.
So you can enjoy those videos
like the real soccer match.
So how they enable this
is that the key feature
is that the video upload
part-- so because the
is the uploaded video, actually.
Though I'm going to explain
the sample code in Java,
but, of course, you can use
the other client libraries,
such as for php, and
then Python, Ruby,
and [? Sheesha. ?] But
this is a mobile summit,
so I'm going to introduce
the Java samples.
So the video upload is really
easy to use and intuitive.
This call is showing how
to upload video in Java.
So the flow is really easy.
So first you open the file
and then set the file size
onto the media content.
And then call the YouTube
method, the video insert
method, and then pass the media
content instance into them.
And just execute the API.
So that's it.
So the name of the
method is video.insert,
which is the same as the
actual [? list of ?] APIs name.
So you can intuitively use
the YouTube API client library
in Java if you know the
URL of the YouTube API.
So then, once you've succeeded
in uploading video to YouTube,
then you may think
that you want to make
your application
possible to play
user uploaded video
inside your application.
So in order to do
that, there is the
in game playback
features in YouTube API.
So this is how you can
integrate the player
API inside your
Android application.
So first of all,
in the layout file,
you can specify the YouTube
player view like this.
And after that, you can extend
the YouTube basic activity
class for your own
customized playback section.
So this is really easy
because-- so you're
going to implement each
interface for each event.
So then every single handler
is handled by these interfaces.
So once you implement
the interface,
then you can customize
how the player works.
So this is a really easy
to use native player API.
So I just introduced
some use cases
that is going to upload
user-generated gameplay
video onto YouTube
and explain how
to play them inside
your application.
But I haven't
explained how to record
the gameplay of the users
because, unfortunately, YouTube
API does not provide
any recording service.
So the recording
part has to be done
by yourself or others
third party libraries.
But, fortunately, some
gameplay SDK's are provided
by a third party, such as
the [? play ?] showing here.
And so once you
integrate those kind
of SDK's inside
your application,
then you can record the user
play and to the video file.
And then you can automatically
upload that recorded video
directly onto the YouTube.
So the left one is the screen
shot of the "Bad Piggies."
So does play "Bad
Piggies," or has anyone
played "Bad Piggies?"
Oh, you did.
So did you try the
recording feature?
AUDIENCE: No.
YOSHIFUMI YAMAGUCHI: No.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
YOSHIFUMI YAMAGUCHI: OK.
So this is the sample video
recorded by the Everyplay SDK.
Oh, why?
[VIDEO GAME SOUND]
So can you see the rec icon
on the top of the video?
So the key is that
the user is not
trying to create
the great content.
But they just play the video.
And then, if they press
the YouTube Upload
to YouTube button, they
can share the content
onto the YouTube.
So the developers don't
have to do anything,
just implement the upload
feature and then let the game
players to [INAUDIBLE]-- let
the game players [INAUDIBLE]
the application on the internet.
That is the key.
So, but, in some cases,
you cannot use these kind
of third-party libraries,
or you'd like to implement
the recording part by yourself.
So I'd like to explain how
you can implement that part.
So this is just an explanation.
So in this case, this
is using the Unity.
It's also a framework.
But I think you can
do it by yourself.
So at first, you create a game,
and then users start gameplay.
And then you have to pull
out the audio and video
frames from the game.
And then once you
get those frames,
you have to encode those
frames into the video file.
So in this case, I'm using the
web-m, and VPA, and [? Vobis ?]
for a container and
the video format,
and audio format, respectively.
But you can also use these such
as MPEG-4, and H.264, and mp3,
respectively.
So this is just an explanation.
So anyway, you have to
encode those captured frames
into the video file
using, like, FFM
tech inside the application.
And then once the video file is
created, the rest of the stuff
is very easy.
Just code the video
insert YouTube API,
and then that is going to
be uploaded on the YouTube.
So the last part is really
easy, but the first part
is kind of hard.
So I recommend you to take
advantage of those kind
of the gameplay SDK's.
And if you want to
try some samples which
is using YouTube API,
especially for uploading videos,
please find these two samples.
One is YouTube
[INAUDIBLE] for Android,
and then the other
is that for iOS.
And then the YouTube is putting
the sample code on the GitHub
and showing here,
GitHub.com/YouTube.
And if you go down
to some repositories,
then you can find YouTube
[? direct light ?] Android.
And then here, you YouTube
[? direct light ?] iOS.
So if you are interested
in how to upload
the video through the
Android apps or iOS app,
then please try this.
And then maybe
you can find a way
to use the upload
API at the same time.
OK.
So let me show-- so the
video upload part has
been explained in
the previous slides.
So here, I'd like
to introduce how
to authorize and authenticate
your application using API.
So YouTube API is
using OAuth2 for
authorization/authentication,
like other Google services.
And the flow is kind of
really straightforward.
So here, at first, you
can create credentials
using the Google
account confidential,
using OAuth2 method.
Then this part is just
for the error handling.
Then, after that, just
assign the account name
to the credential.
So then the preparation for
credential is ready now.
Then you can pass
this credential
to the YouTube
service builder here.
With this YouTube instance, you
can call any method, like video
insert, or video
update, or search,
or some other old YouTube API.
And this is for [? 100 ?].
But in the case of iOS,
which the sign in flow
is also really straightforward.
Just call this--
where is the pointer?
So call this method once.
So it's really straightforward.
So, so far, we have focused
on the video upload.
So archived video upload.
But now I'm going to introduce
how to integrate live streaming
API inside the application.
So let me show an example.
[MUSIC  PLAYING]
So all it's showing is
only the recorded video
using the Arigato Gaming device.
How can I go to the next slide?
But what I want to introduce
is that so this device
allows users to put the
live streaming onto YouTube
without doing any
complicated configuration.
So the users just have to plug
the HDMI cable into this device
and connect to the PC.
Then, the user can broadcast
their gameplay online.
So this device is highly
connected to the YouTube.
And then, if user has
the YouTube account,
then user can broadcast the
gameplay with only one click.
So this is enabled users
to exposing the gameplay
onto the YouTube in real time.
And there is another
solution using
YouTube API for live
streaming called XSplit.
So XSplit is just
a software solution
for our live streaming.
But if the user
launches this software,
then user can put the
live streaming using
any arbitrary archived content,
or any screencast stream.
So this is also are
connected to YouTube API.
So then this is how the
YouTube API is working.
So in YouTube live, we call
each live streaming event
as broadcast, left
side, and then we
call each stream, each actual
video live stream setting
as a stream.
Then you can bind the broadcast
and the stream setting
using the API.
Then after that, the YouTube
API returns the actual endpoint
where a user has to put
the live streaming, too.
So the device, or software,
just sends a live stream
to the endpoint, which is
returned by a YouTube API.
And then, if you are
a YouTube partner,
if you insert a cue
point to the live stream,
then you can insert
the in-stream ad
inside live streaming.
So you can monetize
live streaming
as well using the API.
So this is the
implementation of creating
the broadcast [? spot ?].
But like other YouTube APIs,
it's really straightforward.
So just create the instance,
the broadcast instance,
then set live streaming
title, and then set
the metadata of what
time does the live start,
and what time does live end.
Then create the live
streaming status.
Then, if you want to
make the live as private,
at first, then set
the private here.
Then, using the live
broadcast insert method,
you can create the live event
using this broadcast instance.
So this is really
straightforward,
same as a live
video insert method.
And yesterday, a
Korean-translated version
of the YouTube API is out.
So if you get interested
in using the upload API,
or live API, or some
other YouTube API,
then please refer to this site.
So if you access to
developers.google.com/YouTube--
so maybe, at first, you access
through the English version
one.
Then, at the very right
bottom of the page,
you can find a Select button.
This here is a Hangul.
If you change the menu,
then you can get access
to the Korea version
of YouTube API docs.
So for example, if you access
through the data API, and then
version 3, then although
it's translated into-- oh no,
this is not one.
So the one with the English
tag is not translated yet.
But all others--
something, for example,
if you access to documentation
for each methods,
you can get the whole translated
version of the YouTube API.
So this is really easy
to try because then you
have API explorer.
So here, you don't
have to write any code.
So just put properties here
inside a form and just press
the Execute button.
Then you can see how it works.
So if you get interested
in YouTube API,
please access to this page.
And please play
around how it works.
So today's summary.
So the huge stats of
YouTube show how much
the users spend their
life on the YouTube.
And also the gamers watch
more user-generated content
than the official trailers.
So it's really
important for developers
to create some system that
lets users generate content.
And then also why use
the YouTube APIs is
that YouTube API
itself is the YouTube.
But the YouTube API
enables developers
to utilize those YouTube
features outside of YouTube.
It means inside the application.
And then also, after that, I
introduced the developer system
around YouTube.
And you learned some successful
use cases in creation
[INAUDIBLE] YouTube using
data API, and the upload API,
and the live streaming API.
So if you get interested in
YouTube and the YouTube API,
please utilize those.
And then I hope you
are going to achieve
a great success
through the YouTube.
So here's some reference.
So if you get interested in
the YouTube, and YouTube API,
please access these.
And thank you for coming here.
And thank you for listening
to my presentation.
Thank you.